hi my name is pizza and this is my
question to you my question is hi Peter
so you're asking how strong is the
radiation of the Sun well that's a
interesting question the Sun radiates
light as you know in the visible
spectrum but also in the ultraviolet and
infrared and if you add up all that
radiation that hits the earth it turns
out that there's about a kilowatt or 1.4
kilo watt of power you know it takes
about a hundred watts to power an
ordinary light bulb about ten ordinary
lightbulbs on every square meter of the
earth if you add up all the earth as a
as a big surface so if you add up all
the square meters on the surface of the
earth you get about a almost a Giga
gigawatt a gigawatt is a billion ten to
the nine watts and a Giga gigawatt is
about 10 to the 18 watts so that's a lot
of power now then you could you could
easily figure out knowing how far the
earth is from the Sun and the fact that
the area of a sphere of radius R is 4 PI
R squared what the total amount of
radiation emitted from the Sun is and
another way of figuring that up by the
way is knowing that the temperature of
the Sun is around 6,000 degrees and the
Sun is a flat almost a blackbody and so
once you know its size and it's 10
sure you know how much power in radiates
so I'll leave that as an exercise to you
to do those calculations and find out
how much radiation how much energy per
second is emitted by the Sun but let me
get back to that first number about a
kilo watt per square meter of solar
energy is falling on the earth so we
could add it that up as we just did and
get about a gigawatt a Giga gigawatt of
of power that's a lot of power we could
compare that with how much power we use
as human beings you know we power our
automobiles that we power our houses we
have air conditioned and light and all
the electricity all the power that we as
human beings used adds up to about 20
terra watts that's about 20,000
gigawatts 20,000 gigawatts of energy
which is very small compared to a
billion gigawatts of energy so we only
use about one part in 20,000 of the
energy that the Sun deposits on the
earth now actually some of that energy
that falls on the earth is radiated out
and the greenhouse effect that is
causing all of our concern about global
warming is due to the fact that not
enough is radiating now and some of that
energy goes into creating a movement of
air and heating up the earth and making
the winds flow and but we could easily
capture much more than we do of that
solar energy and solve all of our energy
and perhaps that's the ultimate solution
to problems of energy consumption
without co2 admission just to tap a
small fraction of all that Norma's
amount of solar energy that's falling on
the earth so thanks for your question